well hello there
okay that was a really creepy intro i
should probably reconsider that one
anyway
what is up guys my name is
and i got a bit of gameplay for you guys
and this isn't call of duty what the
hell i am unsubscribing right now
because you promised my black ops
gameplay and this isn't black ops this
is black like tangled down these are not
cool i'm subscribing right now
anyway this is black light tango down i
just play this game a lot i really
really like this game
but you couldn't play it because you
know i'd be spending most of my time in
the lobbies and just being afk and all
the sudden the game started and i was
like oh i missed it and then or it would
be like yeah you need you need five
players to create a game and then you
constantly wait with four out
three other guys so you before people in
the lobby and then someone leaves and
right after that someone else joins and
you're like
god damn it why didn't you stay just one
more minute
uh but they fixed that you can now join
games in progress
is that how you say it i think thinks
that's always it uh which is awesome
because now i can finally play this game
so you guys please don't unsubscribe to
me
i really actually have one more
subscriber than my friend now so
that makes it even more important i
think now my dick size is
officially bigger than his i don't know
if it's
size or length though
anyway i guess it's not important uh
today's friday and i freaking love
fridays i don't know why i keep saying
freaking sounds like i want to be table
or something [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] now
i feel much better hello
anyway i
host migration here
what the hell and stalking your facebook
profile
host migration stocking facebook profile
variation available
show his name
he's the kind of dude who doesn't care
but i'm gonna probably gonna blur it
anyway anyhow
that guy and i used to play a lot of
world of warcraft we used to play arena
together
and that was a lot of fun i love playing
arena um i kind of miss that
but he has he has a girlfriend now he
doesn't play much anymore now we neither
of us play world warcraft anymore i
guess we both got alive but i guess he
wins a little bit for the girlfriend
part uh
i don't know
but he plays heroes on new earth and i
don't
i'm not really too good at that game so
i don't know i'm prob probably going to
play dota 2 though because that game is
fun at least dota but i'm just horny for
whatever valve does like
at least you can play their freaking
games
instead of [ __ ] black ops and it runs
like diarrhea anyway that nature was
pretty damn horrible please don't hate
me guys i'm doing my best
yeah
best here
and anyway i cut this video short
because
uh i don't know team deathmatch are like
10 minutes
so i don't know i just thought that
watching this saying oh two minutes
remaining well why do you know i just
thought that would be more interesting
to watch or something i don't know at
least there was like a top rank in the
video and he reached credit and that
just makes me so happy it tickles my
my genitals i should not have said that
anyway
uh
i don't know i feel like i can do so
much better at this game so much easier
like and now i think my kd is like 3.8
and in cod it's like 2.4 in tdm at least
and this is like without much effort so
i don't know i don't know i like this
game
much it's kind of tricky i don't know
what i feel what are my feelings it's
like when you're alive and you're like
do i really like this person or the [ __ ]
do i know anyway
today's friday and i freaking like stop
saying freaking [ __ ] [ __ ]
i like fridays i didn't have that
awesome friday feeling but i have now oh
yeah i was going to tell you about
uh i was going to tell you guys about a
game it's called
the game
me and me a friend of mine you should
place it and i thought since this was
friday you might get go out and get
drunk and this game actually only works
if you're drunk because it's too easy to
do if you're sober we actually tried it
out so but it wasn't fun at all so
explaining it uh i'm hoping you're drunk
now because it's going to be more fun i
guess
hopefully hopefully it will be
understandable as well oh 30 seconds i
gotta hurry anyway the game rules are
pretty much that if someone says uh-oh
then
the other guy i have to say oh
or he could switch it and say beauty and
then the other guy has to say
so it could be like oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
pewdiepie
and if someone [ __ ] up then you get to
smack their face like that no not really
but i don't know get a shot or something
i don't i don't know try it out if you
want to i doubt anyone will anyway that
was pretty much the game and i'm gonna
blur that out it score was
[ __ ] i didn't have a chance to see it i
think it was 38 and four or something
anyway uh
subscribe to my channel